- [Announcer] Garlands,
gift bags, and applause.
This plane full of Chinese
tourists was greeted in Thailand
by cabinet ministers
and a crowd of onlookers
holding welcoming banners.
- Now we can say Thailand
freely opened for all tourists.
- [Announcer] They were the
first to visit the country
since China reopened its borders
after three years of heavy restrictions.
Before the pandemic,
Chinese travelers were the largest source
of tourism revenue globally,
spending $255 billion around the world.
But travel analysts say limited flights,
travel restrictions, and lower demand
are slowing down the return
of these big spending,
international visitors, at least for now.
For nearly three years,
strict quarantine requirements
have kept millions of Chinese tourists
from traveling abroad.
Travel into and out of mainland China
dropped by more than 94% to
8.8 million trips in 2021,
from 170 million in 2019.
But in January, China's government
removed the restrictions
that stifled the flow of these travelers,
who were particularly
important for tourism hotspots
in the US, Europe, and Southeast Asia.
Take Singapore for example,
where visitors from mainland China
made up nearly a fifth of
international arrivals in 2019
and spent around $3.1 billion.
Businesses in Southeast Asia have lost
an estimated 6 million
tourism jobs since 2019
and have struggled to find
alternative sources of revenue.
Now, even as some countries
begin welcoming back
Chinese tourists, analysts
say the regional industry
won't recover until 2024,
and maybe even longer
for the rest of the world.
So why will recovery take so long?
Firstly, flight capacity is limited.
When China closed its borders
to international travel
in 2020, many airlines
rerouted their fleets
to serve other destinations.
And now, with high fuel
and operational costs,
many are not rushing to
resume pre-pandemic routes
to and from China.
Days after China reopened its borders,
there were only 16 international
flights scheduled to depart
from Beijing Capital
International Airport.
And then there's the travel restrictions.
Some governments are wary
about rising COVID cases
coming out of China and have
implemented travel rules.
In December, Italy,
traditionally among the top destinations
for Chinese tourists
became the first EU country
to introduce COVID testing on arrival
for those coming from China.
Many other countries have
announced similar requirements,
prompting China to criticize the measures.
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Announcer] And lastly,
the demand for traveling
abroad is still low.
Today, flights in and
out of Northeast Asia,
the region that includes China,
are still about 60% below
pre-pandemic levels.
And the lunar new year holidays
are expected to see people
mostly travel domestically
as they reunite with family.
That means demand for
international flights won't pick up
until the second quarter of the
year, according to analysts.
The ripple effects of this
delayed recovery in travel
have wide economic implications.
Sectors that are connected to tourism,
like hospitality and luxury goods,
have suffered while Chinese
tourists stayed home.
Shares of some luxury goods
companies such as LVMH
have rallied since China announced
the easing of restrictions.
And analysts say it's
just one of the industries
that have high hopes for
when Chinese travelers
start spending again.